you know i'm still getting over the
tragedy loss of my wife she was such a
strong female woman with nice heavy
breasts
don't eat the burrito
good morning carly tammy looks like
you're keeping the machines running
smoothly whatever carly will be the
first to go what's your favorite movie
uh die hard wrong jake's favorite movie
is die hard i asked you for larry's
favorite movie two people can have the
same favorite movie they can but they
don't larry's favorite movie is failure
to launch say it say my favorite movie
is failure to launch
my favorite movie sailor lunch
oh larry
hope you like kids birthdays hey
everyone someone just volunteered to be
dj b day
here at the fun zone we live by one rule
when it's your birthday you are always
cool parents and kids are all the same
watch
as i do a dance
to your name
derek
did
again i'll go to hell larry that's my
walking group
oh greg
i don't think your wrist is supposed to
move like that no okay it's been like
this since i broke it playing football
in high school
fine i petted a horse too hard
[Music]
well it's an all-terrain vehicle so yeah
you can do donuts in your living room
these machines are death traps if you
purchase one you will be maimed you
won't be maimed most of the injuries are
internal
the ignition is here written atvs before
antiquing
in the berkshires
corn dog puned by go-kart it's pwned but
that was really adorable
hello larry it's your neighbor greg can
i try your hot tub out i'm thinking of
getting one
it probably goes without saying but it's
chill to whiz in this thing
i mean i have been you can if you want i
haven't been if you haven't have you i
haven't have you ruth i'm gonna be
straight with you i accidentally knocked
up a woman greg you know me i see a pair
of thick weighty breasts and all logic
flies out the window bucket i'll just
take your biggest bucket of bullets
adios constant pool of sweat in my taint
see you never drive through
vape station i was detained once by
taylor swift's security team but that
was misunderstanding
she's probably going to write a song
about me we got to get out of here we
love killing any animal this is bad
figgis has the marshall and now he knows
where we are we're sitting ducks that's
the worst kind of duck tell that to the
dutch hook bill
ugh
so much drier than i would have thought
did i want it to be wet jake right sorry
it's holding an eyeball in my hand no
big deal here we go i can't stay mad at
you
huh
we committed several felonies and
escaped from jail yeah but we were just
doing what we had to do we're the good
guys
this is what they all think
we just shared one of the longest kisses
of my life what if you were going
through a drive-through and a puppy dog
took your order nobody drinks water here
chew something blue or green
okay i guess i'll go in for uh the
blazing blue red very cooler extreme
colon code rad what sounds better liquid
moan or turnpike right on bro i'm fine
except i was impaled on a metal pipe
oh my god
oh my
god it's gonna be fine
oh my god this is gonna hurt but i'm
gonna get you through it
oh god i'm gonna throw up into your cut
ah i saw inside of you how are humans
alive maybe we've grown apart maybe
she'll be repulsed by my frosted tips i
was gonna defrost them before i saw her
for the first time do i know you from
somewhere
do you watch a lot of pornography cause
i'm in most of it do we have any weapons
i have the pipe we pulled out of me i
would sooner surrender than go anywhere
near your gooey body pipe
here we go
and let's go
[Applause]
i hope you're a better kisser than home
what wow why did i say that if you're
more favorite for free well good talk
don't die holt had very soft lips which
i hadn't said that one either boost my
bottom i'm boosting boost my bottom
booster
all right i had to live in florida for
six months it's the worst have you tried
the pizza down here yeah it's the most
disgusting thing i've ever tasted it
somehow burned my mouth and is cold at
the same time but none of that changes
the fact that you're about to go to
prison for the rest of your life
get out of the car
young cheesy
[Music]
[Applause]
lost and found at the storage facility
they have boxes of them they're
everywhere
you